mindfulness is about this it is about
finally waking up one day and saying I'm
the boss of being here I have a mind I
can do better with it than letting it
scare me all the time than letting it
remind me of everything never bothered
me that's not fun is it right and let's
say you're going to give a talk in your
class all right A lot of people your
mind give a little trouble before that
doesn't it oh my God what if I forget my
lines does anybody's mind ever do that
to them doesn't that help you perform
better no it doesn't so I could just sit
here for the whole hour and a half and
remind you of how ridiculous it is what
goes on inside your head right it is
worse than an arm that won't stop doing
this and some people sit there and say
they want to sit there and say but it's
beneficial to go over this stuff yes if
something happens to you and you make a
mistake sit down look at it pay
attention learn from it and for God's
sakes not for the next 20 years why do
they do that if I hadn't done that this
would have happened you understand that
you can't tell me there's a benefit
there is no benefit it's just that you
haven't learned how to work with this
thing called mine need motivation watch
your top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I quit I'm
a business partner I struggled to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so taylorson from one of the
best Michael a singer and my take on his
top ten rules of success enjoy
rule number two understand the three
ring circus basically there are three
categories or groups of objects of
Consciousness that your Consciousness is
aware of one is the outside world if you
close your eyes you don't see the
outside world if you open your eyes ah
there it is okay it comes in I discussed
in the book goes deep tries to be
somewhat scientific so that we fit into
an intellectual model because everything
is logical and and intellectual and
reasonable so the factor of the matter
is most people don't think about this
you don't really see through your eyes
your eyes are sensors we call them
senses but they're sensors if they
computer sensors that are picking up
light
turning it into signals that are being
sent up your nervous system you know
Optical nervous Optical nerves and then
it is rendering it inside your mind just
like you look at a flat scene scrap
excuse me a flat screen TV and you look
at it in there that's hard for us to
relate to because we're used our mind is
so intelligent that it creates 3D and
depth perception and everything even
though you're actually back in here
watching what's coming in and I like to
have fun with people I say I'll prove it
to you that it's really just light
that's bouncing off of objects and
coming into your eyes right turn off the
lights
and you won't see anything because then
there's no light bouncing off of things
that's how we think we think of drawth
life therefore I can't see no it's
because I turned off the light there's
no light bouncing off the objects and
coming reflecting back into your eyes
it's kind of neat isn't it all right so
it's it's fun to talk about this stuff
so one thing of the three new circuits
is there's an outside world with all of
its objects and there's a lot of objects
out there the second is that's not all
you receive inside not all you're aware
of inside you're also aware of thoughts
which I'm sure we'll be talking about
deeper so just surface level it you're
aware of thoughts that go on in there
are you not right you you notice your
thoughts are talking to you you notice
you can make your thoughts think
different things so you the
Consciousness the exact same
Consciousness that is aware of the
outside world is aware of your thoughts
they're not separate not categorizing it
this is the Consciousness here's my
thoughts that's the Consciousness this
is the world you can do them both at the
same time they're looking at something
and thinking about it and your same
conscience is the same both and then the
third is your emotions which are quite
different than thoughts and I'm sure
we'll talk more about that but basically
emotions or feelings their vibrations
that come up they're not thoughts or
thought forms you can actually see a
boat in there you can see you know see
words but you can hear words they're
talking to you their voice inside your
head emotions are like that they're just
basically shift in energy patterns
vibrations that you pick up but they're
very strong and they catch your
Consciousness so those are the three
things in the three things Circus the
outside world that you're aware of the
thoughts that are inside your head your
mind and the emotions that emanate from
your heart and the Consciousness gets
distracted by those things that's so
it's really funny that the word
distraction becomes a spiritual word if
you want to think of it that way but
deep spirituality deals with
distractions that's what it's all about
if you weren't distracted by your
emotions distracted by your thoughts or
distracted with the outside world you're
sitting in samadhi the Consciousness
would be able to come back into its
source rule number three is learn about
Karma Yoga Karma Yoga is about
everything else
that's why Karma Yoga is the deepest
yoga it's not about your relationship
with your body with your heart with your
mind or even with your higher bodies
it's about your relationship with the
rest of the world with the rest of
what's unfolding in front of you how do
I interact with the reality of life that
keeps manifesting before me that is the
topic of Karma Yoga and it's often
considered the deepest yoga because it
is so expansive in one's life in fact
one of the deepest spiritual scriptures
in yoga the bhagavad-gita is considered
A Treatise on Karma Yoga
so what is karma yoga what is our
relationship with the world around us
in order to understand that to begin to
truly understand that you have to
understand two things one who are you
who's in there looking out what is the
nature of your being that has a
relationship with the world around you
and the second is what is the nature of
the world outside of you
first is actually quite simple
you are the one who's in there looking
out
this is what the essence of witness
Consciousness and krishnamurti used to
talk about objective observation
you are the indwelling being who looks
out through your eyes hears through your
ears you are the one who knows you have
a body you're the one that was in there
when you were six years old and when you
looked in the mirror you saw a
six-year-old's body now you see whatever
age you are and it will continue on you
are the Consciousness the awareness of
being you see the emotions that are
coming up from your heart you see the
thoughts that are created in your mind
and ultimately you experience great love
and sometimes Bliss as you get deeper
within yourself it's all the same you
there's just one of you there that's you
well what is the nature or the reality
of the world outside of you that is one
of the most fascinating and beautiful
topics
if you turn to science they will tell
you that 13.8 billion years ago there
was this big bang
and subsequent to that there were these
thick gases of hydrogen and helium
that fused together based on gravity and
built the universe as you know it
a wise person realizes that every single
moment of their life
what is unfolding in front of them is
the result of 13.8 billion years of the
universe unfolding and evolving until it
finally landed at their doorstep and
presented the moment that's in front of
them
to them so the world outside of you is
not of your own making
the world outside of you belongs to
science belongs to God it belongs to
Evolution it belongs to cause and effect
it is indeed the moment in front of you
took 13.8 billion years to get there you
can't call it your own you didn't make
it you weren't even here
the other way to know that the world
outside of you has absolutely nothing to
do with you it belongs to itself is to
realize that the moment in front of you
is no different than the moment to your
left or the moment to your right or the
moment behind you or the moment anywhere
else in the universe the universe is
expressing itself
everywhere you're just seeing one
particular moment one particular point
you can't say that because it's the part
that you see there's something special
about it it's just the part that you see
so a wise person comes to the point of
realizing that they are inside looking
out what is outside is the result of
creation it is not theirs it doesn't
belong to them it is just passing by and
they just happen to be seeing that
moment so karma yoga raises the Deep
question what then is my relationship to
the world that's unfolding in front of
me if it doesn't belong to me and it
doesn't again let's spend one more
moment with that if I picked you up out
of the moment you're in
and dropped you onto a street in Paris
then that would be the moment you see
obviously that moment was there before
you got there and if I take you away the
moment will be there after you leave it
has absolutely nothing to do with you
eventually a wise person realizes that
it's true of every moment if I walk in a
restaurant
that restaurant existed before I got
there it was going on the people were
there conversations were going on music
was going on whatever food was going on
I then step in I'm just seeing a moment
that already exists when I step out the
moment will keep going on it doesn't
belong to me it belongs to itself
belongs to science belongs to God
it's such a beautiful thing to see that
the world outside of you exists
independent of you you are experiencing
one particular moment of it rule number
four is stop seeing yourself the world
has its ebb and flow it has its cycle
and it should have its cycles and you do
not understand those cycles and you will
never understand those Cycles how could
you possibly do you only see this tiny
bit of life it's a hole its Cycles are
in harmony with its Universal self you
only see the way when it passes by you
say I shouldn't be doing that why
because it messed up my face in my
reflection that's why you'll always do
it in relationship to you you want to
know how wrong you are every single time
you say something's good or bad or right
or wrong or better or worse or preferred
or not preferred I'm going to ask you
based on what every one of those things
are relative term good bad right wrong
preferred not preferred those are
relative terms she doesn't agree she
doesn't agree everyone's got their own
thing don't they they're relative and
I'm going to ask you based on what and
if you're honest you're gonna say based
on based on my view of the world based
on my value system so what who cares
about your value system there's
narcissus again there you are looking
into the universe and seeing the
reflection of yourself and saying that's
what matters so it's you just get to the
point where you stop putting so much
weight on yourself stop being narcissist
your face is just one of 700 billion
things in the universe your spiritual
journey is about ceasing to think that
you matter it is about ceasing to think
that you are the center of your Universe
the universe is the center of the
universe it's about Lake not about face
it just keeps coming back to the same
thing you have to wake up to that so
your spiritual growth is not about
getting into yourself or changing your
views or duh you need to go in there and
mess around with your mind is crazy your
mind doesn't matter it's a nothing you
know how long it takes to erase a hard
disc just take a good magnet pass it
across it's gone so it's just
meaningless what you have in there stop
rearranging the darn thing what matters
is life itself God the universe get to
know her how by ceasing to be so
interested in yourself so when you look
into the lake of life and that's what
you're doing every minute of every day
you understand that you're looking into
the lake of life when you look into the
lake of life will you please stop seeing
yourself there's lots and lots and lots
of things out there stop seeing yourself
how do I know that I'm seeing myself I
will give you the biggest clue It Ever
Was it offends you you feel a change in
the force in the energy in the Shakti
flow sometimes you do don't you like
lots of times if you look out into this
Lake of life and it causes a change in
the flow of the chi inside of you you
have projected yourself into life and it
hits your projection I want this to
happen I want that to happen the cause
of suffering is desires Buddha it's all
the same teaching you are projecting
from inside out therefore the innocence
of life is hitting your projections
causing you to suffer causing change to
happen inside your piece it's disturbing
the peace you want to stop that you want
to find true spirituality you have to
let go of projecting yourself onto life
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is let things go
why don't we deal with it exactly the
same insides as we deal with it outside
and just sit there and say yes there are
experience in life that are not pleasant
good I like to learn from them doesn't
mean I want to have them I'm not praying
for them right but if they happen to
present themselves in front of me this
is my opportunity to become a greater
being to be able to handle the reality
of life
there
and so that's also the thorn you talk
about you can carry you let it go let
things go yeah instead of compensating
for them and learning how to be okay
that it's there it's only there because
inside
there are no Thorns there's no physical
being it's etheric inside it's
completely open okay how hard is your
feet to change your mind
later on right okay there's nothing in
there it's it's just it's totally empty
right it's just loose right it's looser
than the clouds so why not make it nice
in there so if something comes in and
it's disturbing yeah I always tell
people if you went through a traumatic
terrible experience when you were young
I wish I could go down there and beat
the people up and go back in time and
protect you oh I would love to do that
but I can't I can't and you can't either
nor can anybody else right so I will
blame
person who mistreated you or did this
thing to you when you were five years
old you're an innocent child right for
causing the Trump that problem then but
they stopped
they went away they moved they died you
know rest I don't care it's whatever
it's over right but you didn't let it be
over for the next 30 Years you did it
I have to blame you for those 30 years I
can't blame them they're not there I
can't blame the experience is not even
happening how dare you blame the
experience that happened 25 years ago
you are the one who chose to keep that
inside of you and let it destroy your
life I always teach this
first let go then if it's still there
deal with it you're going to find out
that 95 of the time once you relax and
let go there's nothing left to deal with
If somebody walks up you say hey Sally
how are you doing she doesn't turn on
say hello she's your friend okay no
there's there's an experience it's not
comfortable what's wrong why shouldn't
you know blah blah does not hear me all
that stuff goes on right relax through
it relax through it okay okay fine
that's what happened now what are you
gonna do about it nothing she's not
there anymore there's nothing to do
right and you're crazy it's the next
time you see something why didn't you
say that
you won't do that because you handled it
there's no reason to say anything what a
nice person you are maybe she didn't
hear you maybe she's in a bad mood who
cares
right so if you are willing to let go
you're going to find out the vast
majority of the time there is nothing to
do about it except let go rule number
six is have awareness if someone were to
listen to this conversation from the
seat of awareness what what would that
be like how would they do that but
that's jumping ahead a whole lot but
let's start there okay
you are aware
people don't pay attention to the fact
that they're aware but obviously they're
aware you see through your eyes you hear
through your ears and you you feel touch
and so on
who does that what does that your eyes
don't see you see through your eyes your
skin passes messages back to you your
ears pick up sound vibration and send
them back to you who is that in there
and where in there it's not really
everywhere there's a place inside of
yourself from which you listen that's
why some meditation techniques are very
beautiful they tell you to just listen
listen to quiet listen to whatever
sounds there pay attention listen then
you really realize you're in there
trying to listen
so basically but but you're asking a
deep question the Deep answer is you are
inside and if you meditate and you pay
attention and work with witness
Consciousness you're going to find out
that there is a place in there where you
are and that the sites that are coming
in are outside of you even inside your
thoughts are outside of you you'll feel
that they're at a distance from you
because you're sitting in a center of
Consciousness and then you're projecting
your Consciousness onto objects of
Consciousness rule number seven is be
mindful I would love to feel that
what we talk about today and what you
end up doing with it can help you be the
best of whatever you chose to be because
what we're talking about it's your
choice which you choose to be all right
and you have a lifetime to do it but
there are things that can help you be
that and one of those like I said the
most simple level is you take decent
care of your body if you don't take
decent care of your body it doesn't do
well does it and when it's not doing
well you can't do well you can't go to
work you can't concentrate and so on
I want to talk about what mindfulness
really is Right gets pigeonholed into
different things it really is about
saying can we have a discussion about
what you're doing with your mind there
that's mindfulness
be mindful of what you're doing with
your mind so what does that mean you
raise your hand you say to me well I use
my mind to study I say wonderful great I
hope you do well at it I use my mind to
do research I'm into research wonderful
that's a great thing to do with your
mind I use your mind I love to read and
learn about history and whatever it is
that you are doing with your mind be
mindful of what your mind is doing or
you're going to be in big trouble
what is your mind doing it's really very
very easy
I guarantee you it takes you 10 seconds
you won't like what you see what you're
going to see is that when you are not
using your mind when am I not using your
mind when you're driving down the road
going somewhere when you're sitting on
the potty whatever you want to call it
right all the moments you take in your
life where you are not consciously doing
something I guarantee you there's
something going on in your mind what's
it doing oh my God I can't believe I
said that I am so embarrassed that was
ridiculous if I hadn't said that I was
doing does anybody's mind do that answer
me okay what is the benefit of that
the answer is zero do you understand
that how about this you're driving down
the road you're going on a vacation or
driving to Miami and there's a sign a
billboard on the road and it reminds you
of a relationship that your problem you
had with your father or your mother 25
years ago and your mind starts
reiterating the discussion as if it was
going on now or your ex-husband or
whatever it is and it's still going on
in there isn't it what in the world is
that of what benefit is that very few of
you in business in relationships in life
would allow a cost-benefit analysis take
place of which the cost is 100 and the
benefit is zero and you would still do
it
correct that's what I'm telling you that
is the cost is a hundred percent and the
benefit is absolutely zero all it does
is cause you trouble it makes you
neurotic it makes you nervous it makes
you scared do you understand that so why
are you tolerating that that's what
mindfulness is about rule number eight
is acknowledge your vulnerability we
Define a world inside ourselves that
supports our self-concept and we need
that because we're hiding from ourselves
behind the self-concept right
and because we Define the world that way
we need the world to be that way right
but the world has nothing to do with
what we made up the world is what it is
it's reality it's it's beating to a
whole different realm it's beating to
science it's beating like hey then our
rain today it's my birthday that's
stupid dumb what are you doing in the
rain has nothing with your birthday has
to do with meteorology and low pressure
zones right so you've now left yourself
vulnerable to the unfolding of reality
is going to destroy you right
so that's what you were saying and
that's absolutely true so even if I sit
down and I write my list
to begin the day
and then I follow that list in order to
basically make myself feel less insecure
the truth is I'm more vulnerable yes
because things may interrupt that list
that I don't have control over and then
I will be sort of subject to that
experience
if you're living your life to hide from
yourself
you're not going to get anywhere
it starts you ask me how do you do this
it starts when you say I don't really
want that anymore
I don't want my state of being to be
completely dependent upon somebody
else's mood upon how somebody else does
or doesn't do or
et cetera et cetera et cetera you know
when the unfolding of the weather for
the unfully of the world right I want to
find my true being I want to find me in
here and be okay then I'll come into the
world it's not that you don't come into
the world let me come into the world and
be motivated by love be motivated by
compassion be motivated by creativity by
inspiration instead of be motivated by
fear which is what we are motivated by
right okay it's like the most powerful
of us try to stay really powerful
because the thought of I mean some of
these very powerful people the minute
they're out of office or out of this or
finances go wrong they're jumping off
buildings
right or wrong right it did happen
didn't it right okay that's because they
were not powerful
they were supported by something because
they were needing and then that it was
weak and that strength came from
conditional like a conditional State the
moment that conditional State went away
well it's over I don't want to face this
rule number nine is meditate why would
meditation work what's meditation got to
do with me who's in here and struggling
with myself
meditation is very very simple in the
simplest sense
the simplest meditation nowadays that's
taught is 15 minutes in the morning 15
at night sit down and watch your breath
go in and out well what's so Holy by
watching your breath go in and out
what's that got to do with yoga
if you are watching your breath go in
and out you are not watching your mind
complain about what's going on
you're not letting your mind you're not
watching the mind that is participating
in the game of what I want what do I not
want and how do I make it happen you are
instead focusing your awareness on the
breath going in and out believe it or
not that will completely change your
life why for the very reason that you're
not participating in the Disturbed mind
the mind will always be disturbed if the
foundation of the mind is what do I want
what do I not want and how do I make it
happen
that is very disturbing because you have
pitted yourself against the unfolding of
reality in front of you if you watch
your breath go in and out or any other
technique of meditation you use whatever
is comfortable to you it works for you
if you're watching your breath go in and
out you're not watching your mind live
your life decide what should be
happening and getting upset or excited
about it that very Act of not watching
the Disturbed mind permits you you in
there the one that I said are you in
there hi
you're in there but you're watching your
mind all the time and participating in
the mind's attempt to make things be the
way it wants and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is be happy inside every single moment
is an exciting challenge to do your best
to bring your A game to everything
that's going on right it's like sports I
shouldn't talk about it now but anyways
you know sometimes we win something we
lose the question is did you enjoy the
game did you get better because of it if
you played a competitor that was better
than you that's wonderful you learned
you understand that it's the same thing
with relationships if you're in a
relationship and it didn't work out
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
that did you learn did you grow are you
better now to move on with your life
every single moment of life is a
learning experience do you understand
that the point that I see I get close to
people I say to you you are always
better on I'm in trouble and I'll step
back you are always better off having
had an experience than not having had it
you are a holder person because you had
an experience do you understand that if
you didn't ever travel somewhere then
you didn't have an experience if you
didn't ever fall in love you don't know
anything about it you're a novice you're
nothing right you are when you have an
experience when life gives you the gift
of an experience and you experience it
and you learn from it how can you tell
me you're not better off than you were
before you had the experience it can't
make you worse off unless you resist the
experience
then it can really make you worse off
candidate if you don't like the
experience and you resist it it can ruin
your life but the fact that you got to
have the experience is really special
it's a special thing it's a thank you
this gives you a taste of how a mindful
person lives but you can't just decide
to live like that because then you're
going to suppress the issues you have
inside right you're going to come to me
and say but what if somebody dies but
what do I do if this happens right you
didn't catch on yet right get yourself
together be happy inside be whole Feel
Complete right Feel Love pouring up
inside of you because you don't have
this junk stored inside of you then go
out and bring that into this world with
enthusiasm with passion with love right
and interact with every single thing
that life brings before you with a sense
of honor and respect and gratitude for
the right to be able to do that you have
the right to live like that if you're a
student love going to school don't go to
schools they can graduate and then go
get a job and say what are you crazy
school is one of the nearest college
that's got to be one of the neatest
experience you'll ever have in your
entire life you understand that
somebody's paying for you
don't go and listen to smart people tell
you stuff you didn't have to go on the
web and read they sit there and tell you
and what do you do I went to sleep like
come on right you get to the point or
you or you I can't wait to get on and
meet my boyfriend it's always about
something else the reason is because
you're not okay and if you're not okay
you can't enjoy what's happening to you
you have to be looking for the thing
that will be okay that will make you be
okay so we have the groundwork down the
problem here is that you're not okay
inside if you were okay inside your life
would be totally different wouldn't it
you understand that like relationships
you're wrong if you think a relationship
is supposed to make you feel loved
is supposed to make you feel needed and
whole and important that's wrong that's
wrong you're supposed to feel love to
start with that's natural love is part
of your being you're supposed to feel
whole and complete within yourself right
tremendous openness and power right now
go out and share it with another person
that's a relationship don't need and
then get upset because they didn't give
it to you never say that there's no way
it's my view I've done it for 45 years
right there's no way that if you can't
fix what's wrong with you inside there's
someone else is going to do it
they don't even know you they get their
own problems
what you want to do is say what's behind
the anxiety so when when people talk I
don't help people make decisions but we
talk about decision making is the first
thing that matters is what's your motive
not what should you do if how can you
figure out what to do if you don't even
know your motive right and my you became
the spiritual teacher with every word
you said about this which is start from
the point of view do I want to get a
house or not
well okay yes I like to have a house all
right can I afford a house don't worry
about what house what's your motive it's
very simple you know it's just I'm just
on to express myself and have a house
and and that's that and then stop there
don't say it has to be a certain way
when it's all said and done if you're
afraid of making the wrong decision who
defined it is wrong you well then don't
that's not what I was saying right if
you don't Define it as wrong I was a
builder okay you know before my personal
program before the program company I did
go with love my company I built this
house for this beautiful lady all right
who happened to be the manager of the
local bank and her name was Penny dollar
I swear to God her name was Penny dollar
right this is a long time ago back in
the 80s and basically she once came to
me and sat there and said I'm so scared
I said look I I'm gonna build a
beautiful house for you we've got it
everything's fine so I step in nights I
can't sleep what are you worried about
isn't it turning out nice I'm afraid
listen to this I'm afraid that I will
build the house and then I'll go to plug
in a lamp and the cord won't reach the
outlet wow
thank you I said wow that's why they
make a stingy course
I was gonna say that's why they make
therapists but yes this whole thing
about abundance and attracting to
yourself what it is that you want and
how to use mantras and spirituality to
make sure you have what you want true
spirituality is about not wanting is
about being filled with joy from inside
and then sharing that outside it's not
about attracting to yourself what you
want people ask me is there a law of
attraction yes and you better be scared
of it because if it's true that you
attract what your mind is thinking you
better take a look at what your mind is
thinking what about your mind all day
when it's complaining and it's yelling
at people and it doesn't like stuff but
if you're attracting that way so you
eventually catch on that it is not about
getting what you want it is about
learning to find out that what you
really want is to stay open and not have
conditions on that openness and then it
comes down to how do you do that are
people capable of doing that or is that
just reserved for you know some special
beings Buddha and Christ that have
walked the face of the Earth everybody
is capable of that if I tell you to pick
up five thousand pounds you may not be
able to do that so I've told you to do
something that you have never done and
you're not doing it so you may not be
able to do it but if you're actually
already doing something and I tell you
not to do it you're always capable of
that because you're the one who's doing
it so inside you are the one who's
closing your heart you close it you are
the one who's closing your mind you do
that they're your thoughts it's your
feelings they're nobody else's so you
are in there doing these things so if I
tell you the way to stay open is to not
close I don't teach how to stay open
that's more like finding out how to get
what you want I'm interested in you
learning to not close but a difference
if I say to you I want you to open your
heart right now you wouldn't even know
how to start
but if I say to you somebody says and
you don't like don't close you know
where to start right because it's
happening inside of you and you see the
tendency to do it all I'm asking you to
do is don't do that I'm telling you that
will take you the whole way don't worry
about opening worry about not closing
there are going to be events that unfold
in your life that naturally open you a
beautiful sunset a bird singing
sometimes you get what your mind wants
all right you open great nothing wrong
with that don't close
how come it only lasts a minute I'm
going to see a beautiful sunset you feel
like oh my God I looked into the face of
God then you go right back into your
mind with all your problems why
why don't you learn to not close why
don't you get some openness start to
work with yourself to not close and this
is how to get what you really want the
teeth the Deep spiritual teachings are
really teaching you how to get what you
want because what you want is to feel
love and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it instead of asking
why am I not okay why I'm not okay
you're asking what do I need to be okay
that's the major difference of whether
you're growing inwardly or you're
attached to struggling externally
because you think I can only be okay if
I get the things that I got before
or similar you extrapolate right things
that made me had a relationship and
eighth grade and it was so beautiful and
she was redheaded okay my wife no that's
not true all right
he was redheaded and she left you know
her parents move right and it was never
a bad experience in that relationship it
was just the most perfect relationship
you've ever had right you understand now
if I'm grown up and I I go on a date and
shoot a red hat she redheaded I have a
pretense propensity toward being open
you just asked the question why do we
think we need these things all right
because we're not okay inside and we've
had experiences either you read a book
it'll tell you you need that to be okay
you watch a movie meet somebody you can
have a thought
if I had a Tesla
okay it used to be a Ferrari that's a
Tesla all right I I we had everyone
would be proud of me and I feel like I'm
helping the ecology and so all of a
sudden I'm not okay I'm going to go to
Tesla and if I get a Tesla oh my God for
a while how am I doing wonderful so
that's how you develop your preferences
is through programming you get
programmed by your past experiences when
I was you know 22 23 years old
I realized that that voice was running
my life
and that's what you're saying if it
wasn't comfortable I left
if it you know whatever it was it was
determining what I said it was
determined how I acted it was
determining everything about my life and
yet I didn't know a thing about that
voice why was it saying what it was
saying why why is it like one person and
not another because when you like
somebody your voice says I like her so
right and if all of a sudden it said no
oh I don't think so I don't think then
you don't it's like telling you and your
emotions go along with it and it's this
whole psychological system that's going
on inside so I made the decision not and
I'm not saying people should right but
it's nice to share that I wasn't going
to live my life without understanding
what was going on because it didn't make
sense okay and it already caused a lot
of trouble in my life just like it does
everybody else's all right it's like oh
your relations is so hard and everything
else and changing jobs it just decides I
don't like my boss I don't like the boss
anymore it's telling you that why didn't
it just say I like the boss
like no one actually pays attention to
how much control it has over your life
or why it's saying what it's saying so
what I did was to say I'm going to take
a little sabbatical hiatus
about a year or so I meant to put aside
and devote my life to watching that
voice and figure out why it says what it
says what is my relationship to it and I
in essence dropped out I don't like
teaching that now because people
shouldn't drop out I mean not they
shouldn't but they don't need to and I'm
not teaching them to right but I did I
was it was a I think you know I was in a
doctoral program for economics
University and last year ready to get my
doctorate and I stepped aside and went
into Solitude relative Solitude and I
watched very very carefully and what I
saw made me more uncomfortable than what
you were talking about all right like
watching it when it was in his glory
because you know you pull yourself aside
it's going to say a lot of stuff made me
realize I don't listen to that thing
that thing's crazy it just changed his
mind all the time it says this it says
that like the reason people drink and do
drugs is because that thing's driving me
crazy do you understand that are you
trying to get away from that inner mess
that's going on inside so basically over
the course of many years I started an
experiment which was what would happen
if I didn't listen to that
what does that mean it tells you what to
do and so on well what if I listen to
Life instead and that's very subtle what
if the events unfolding in front of me
were more important than whether I like
them or not and I was willing to listen
if I'm meeting this person perhaps it
has some meaning the fact that I'm not
comfortable with them maybe has no
meaning right and I started practicing
letting go of myself instead of letting
go of what it told me to and and
sometimes it told me to do something
sometimes I wouldn't do it what I got
was as follows
just because it told me to do it is not
going to be the reason I do it just
because it told me not to do it isn't or
that it doesn't like it it's not going
to be the reason I don't do it that
doesn't mean that I'm doing or not doing
I will let life the unfolding of Life
the circumstances that unfold in front
of me talk to me instead of that thing
talking to me so that that's the basics
of what I call surrender you're not
surrendering to life you're not
surrendering to people you're not saying
yes to everything you're just basically
saying my head doesn't know what it's
talking about it's just a bunch of noise
he's making a little allergies
it's just a bunch of noise and I'm
better off not listening to that
personal noise doesn't mean
intellectually if I'm solving a math
problem or I'm trying to decide you know
create air conditioning or building I I
built for a while reading plans and so
on the mind's wonderful for that I'm
talking about the personal mind I like
this I don't like that I believe in this
I don't believe in that I want this to
happen oh my God I hope it doesn't rain
tomorrow because I'll die if it rains
that kind of junk just the personal
noise that instead of honoring and
respecting life is judging it and trying
to tell me how to make life be my way
instead of my respecting that life took
13.8 billion years to get here that's
that's a big stick I have right that
every moment in front of me took every
single thing to happen exactly like it
did for 13.8 billion years for that
thing to be in front of me do you
understand that because if you're if
you're a great great great grandmother
didn't meet your great great great
grandfather you're not here
okay the mind is very strong
and one of the things the Mind does is
develop methodologies or ways of
thinking that let it interact with life
and not get hurt and be more comfortable
and it's the ego when we develop a
self-concept and we change it through
our lives but in general there's a
self-concept sitting under there saying
I was the one that did this and I was
the one that went to the school and I'm
the one that went there and the one that
my father left or stayed or whatever the
hell it is excuse me and basically uh
all of this unfolds and you end up
developing patterns of thinking based
upon the experiences you've had all
right and what I'm saying at least
certainly in my experience is that's not
what makes you wake up that's what keeps
you from waking up
all right the fact that you're
identifying with these past experiences
and saying that's who I am well it's not
who you are you are watching your ego
you see it get upset you see it fix
things you see it have Concepts and
Views and Etc et cetera and even you're
obviously very intelligent you can use
your intellect to support the ego to
support that and and so on right and I'm
sure yes you're a very special person
you're an intelligent person and
therefore that becomes part of your
self-concept okay and then you say a
religious person probably self-concept
all of these things are ways you think
of yourself and there's nothing at all
wrong with that it's wonderful you've
been successful you're happy you're
doing well all right I'm not happy I'm
not doing well I just said that
and also like weeping openly at this
moment okay but listen to me right that
identification with your personal self
which is just your mind's thoughts are
what keep you from waking up what do you
really want we talk about wisdom people
talk about attracting to themselves The
Laws of Attraction and all those sorts
of things but the question really is
from a spiritual point of view what do
you really want and religions about what
you're supposed to want and we know how
that works
spirituality is not about that
spirituality is about looking deeply
Within and seeking truth Clarity that's
what it's about so this discussion is
has nothing to do with my feeling what
you should want or are you even feeling
guilty or
weird about what you do want the
question is what do you really want
and the way to do that and I'm going to
be very bad in doing this is to say
here's a piece of paper not really but
figuratively and I want you to write
down what you want just take a little
time don't do it take a little time and
write down what you want and if you're
like most human beings probably first on
the list is a good relationship
something makes me feel important needed
wanted loved secure all that kind of
stuff and so whether you're in a
relationship I'd like it to get better
or someone so should behaves different
ways should understand me better
Etc or if you're not in a relationship
how to find my quotes soul mate somebody
who just fits perfectly with me and just
fulfills the meaning of my life and uh
if we're really honest we write down a
nice house and a Ferrari or at least
some sort of a car and perhaps children
and or perhaps a little time without the
children and we make our list nobody's
judging just be honest you put that down
the purpose of this discussion is no
matter what you put on that list unless
you're very highly evolved
my experience is it's not really what
you want it's not that it's wrong it's
just not really what you want
and the way I prove that is as follows
let's say you put down I want a
relationship I want to meet somebody I
want to have that special relationship
and then I would ask you what if you
walked outside after this conversation
and all of a sudden there was this blush
in front of you and it started burning
like it did to Moses
and talking to you and its opening
sentence was I am the Lord your God
and I would like to discuss some things
with you
and said enough things that it knew
about you to where you were pretty
freaked out that you're actually talking
to an omniscient omniscient omnipotent
being or at least bush
and
the question that gets asked of you is
what would you like what do you want I
can grant whatever you want and having
gone through this exercise with me you
feel God thank God Mickey I'm prepared
this is neat I thought about it and you
say I want a relationship I want to meet
somebody I want to have that that thing
I've looked for my whole life or I want
a house or I want the perfect job I want
a job that makes me you know that
fulfills what I'm looking for
and what this push what God tells you at
that point is I can give you that I have
the power to give you that but there's a
caveat which you probably want to hear
before I give it to you which is
I can give you that perfect person
they will be loyal to you they will stay
with you your entire life
but the caveat is
that you will be completely unfulfilled
you will feel sad every time you come
into the presence
you will not feel any love you will not
feel any joy happiness meaning but
they'll be there and they will dote all
over you and they will just be the most
perfect partner
that they could possibly be
or give you the job that you thought
would be the most amazing thing but it's
Hollow for you you go there and you
thought it would turn you on but it
doesn't
and you just Lowe's going to work and
you're just not excited about it
so therein lies there what do you really
want
because what you're going to find is if
you were given the opportunity to have a
relationship with that person I just
described or have the job I just
described but it didn't do squat for you
and it left you hollow inside you would
say I don't want it in fact if it's
going to make me miserable inside I
really don't want to keep it away from
me
and so to move quickly because we don't
have a little time here then I say you
lied to me when you said it was what you
really wanted
because it isn't true you wanted a
relationship it isn't true you wanted
children it isn't true you wanted money
it isn't true you wanted to travel
around the world it isn't true that you
want it et cetera et cetera what's true
is you wanted to feel good inside
you wanted to feel love you wanted to
feel Joy you want to feel inspiration
excitement meaning those are inner
things there are outer things
you listed the things you listed
because you thought they would give you
what you really want
and so wisdom yoga spirituality
is about going deeper Buddhists talk
about working at the root so the truth
of the matter is the only thing you need
to write you needed to write on a piece
of paper when I asked you what do you
really want
is a sense of total well-being
I want to feel love I want to feel Joy I
want to feel inspiration I want to feel
meaning and depth
[Music]
video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there Consciousness is
creating a reality if you put a picture
of fear into your reality then your
biology Behavior will manifest things to
be afraid of because this is a short
statement but to me it's the most
powerful one